Let's imagine that these spectrums of
questions really do line up with not
just easy and hardness, but
actually line up with understanding.
Which is sort of the assumption
that we made, right?
That anyone can answer the easy
questions, but as you know more,
you can answer the hard questions.
That means the chance of
you being able to sort of,
these questions are aligned, not just in
terms of easy and hard, they're actually
aligned with some underlying
notion of what you actually know.
That your knowledge is, which I'm
just writing as understanding here.
>> Okay
>> Okay,
now furthermore let's imagine you're
understanding were here, okay?
This is really where you are on
this understanding scale.
>> Where Curly is.
>> That's where Curly is.
>> Okay,
in this linear scale of knowledge
>> Yeah so this linear scale of
knowledge about dinosaurs that
apparently requires some background in
calculus, you're basically
here on this linear scale.
Well what would that mean for
you to be right here.
Well it probably means that for
questions way over here,
those really are easy for you and
you'll always get them right.
And for questions way out here,
they're too hard for you and
you're probably going to get them,
almost certainly get them wrong.
But one of the interesting things about
being right at some particular level of
understanding is that
you will occasionally
get some of these things just on this
side of your understanding right.
And you will occasionally get
things just on this side of
your understanding wrong.
Really kind of understanding is
like a probability function.
And I'm going to pretend it's Gaussian,
because that's what we
do in machine learning.
And just kind of say the probability
of you getting a question right depends
upon where your understanding is.
And as you move far in one direction
you will always, always get them right.
Far in another direction you will
always, always get them wrong, but
right around your level of
understanding there's some noise there.
And you'll sometimes get the ones that
are just beyond your understanding
right, and sometimes get the things that
are just below your understanding wrong.
We actually talked about this in
the machine learning class you might
remember when we talked about self
play and learning how to play games.
Do you remember this?
>> Was it a racquetball example?
>> Right we used
a Racquetball example and
we talked about how if you play someone
who is much much better than you
are then basically you never learn
anything because you always lose.
>> That's like the hard questions.
>> Those are like the hard questions.
And if you play someone
you're much much better then
you also never learn anything
because you always win.
>> That's like the easy questions.
>> Right, and in fact the right thing
to do is to play someone who's just
a little bit better or
just a little bit worse than you
that is right around where you are.
And then you'll actually learn something
because the exploration makes sense.
And sometimes you get positive feedback,
sometimes you get negative feedback, and
you learn how to modify your actions and
to learn.
>> Okay, that makes sense to me.
>> Right, and so
by analogy that's what's happening here.
If I can give you questions right around
where your level of understanding is,
then you might learn something.
>> Good.
>> So given that highfalutin boughten
taking it all the way
back to racquetball.
What do you think a good
set of incentives might be?
>> I don't know I mean it's like,
what I wanted to say was,
well you want to be getting
like half of them right.
And so we could pay off the teacher.
Well we I guess we pay the learner off
for getting things right because that's
really what the learner
should be striving for.
But we can pay off the teacher for
keeping things around a half.
But that doesn't really make sense
because then the teacher could do like
I'm just going to randomly choose
from a really easy problem or
a really hard problem, and
on average that will be a half.
So it'll really not be asking any
questions that are in that happy zone.
>> That's good so actually what
you just said is pretty important.
>> And it seems like a really bad idea.
>> No,
no it's actually really important.
You said something really important.
Let me point what you said.
You said that if I tried to pick
a half or any distribution really.
>> Okay.
>> Then he teacher can
always just choose questions
to kind of get that distribution.
And sometimes they'll be incentivized
to, I'll just pick easy ones or
hard ones where I know I'm going to
get the distribution that I want.
And that sort of misses the point.
But what if I don't allow you to
pick the question what if instead
I require you to tell
me where this line is?